all month we've been honoring Asian
Pacific American Heritage Month and to
continue that honoring we asked six
influential Asian Americans to share
their stories with us they include the
author of little fires everywhere
Celeste Eng actress Olivia Munn
award-winning journalist Lisa Ling the
director of crazy rich Asians Jon M Chu
professor and vice chancellor at the
UCLA School of Law
Jerry Kang and CBS News foreign
correspondent Ramey
innocencio they also told us about the
racism they face during the pandemic and
why they're proud of their heritage I
think what it's important to know about
Asian American history is that it is
American history
I'm half Filipino and half Chinese and I
like to add all-american each one of our
lives is a tapestry threaded by our
different experiences culture and family
histories
being asian-american means being part of
one of the most diverse vast
demographics imaginable but it is a
wholly distinctive category unto itself
I think about my dad and my mom both of
which came to this country when they
were in their late teens and twenties I
remember seeing them serve people in the
dining room and occasionally you get the
rude ones didn't know a lick of English
my parents didn't have any money but we
made it work but to be honest throughout
that entire time I never felt Asian
American on the outside I looked Asian
but inside I felt completely American I
just wanted to fit in like everyone else
then my dad sat me down and said John
you have to understand that we are
ambassadors to this area
so we need to give them the best
experience the best food the best
service and be kind so they walk away
not just with their bellies full but
their hearts full but being an Asian
American can be complicated our
culture's accents and mannerisms can be
confusing to some and targets to others
everyone in my family has experience
with dealing with racist comments and
Prejudice in our daily lives I became a
legal scholar exploring the difference
that Asians make how we have been viewed
as forever foreign scapegoated as
disloyal or dangerous or diseased
presented as unfair competitors because
we don't fit the stereotypical image of
what an American looks like we can be
targeted when tensions arise with our
countries of ancestry which is exactly
what's happening now in the wake of the
Koba 19 pandemic so literally 48 hours
ago my cousin in New York texted me
frantically about how she and her young
son had to run from someone yelling
racial slurs on their own Street I could
hear in her voice how terrified she was
her home where she was lived for decades
something doesn't feel like home anymore
nobody deserves to be harassed you don't
need to drape yourself in the red white
and blue and try to convince other
people that they should treat you as an
equal because you are an equal we all
have to use our hearts and to remember
hate is like a virus just like kovat I
am proud of my family and the efforts of
all Asian Americans not only during this
time but throughout our collective
history in this country to be Asian
American means whatever you want it to
if you think there's a box that defines
you stop rip it up in your head and fly
beautiful piece I think ramie really
summed it up there at the beginning Ray
said look I'm half of this I'm half that
but a hundred percent American and and I
really feel like that applies to so many
American citizens in fact all of them
Gail I know you know it's so funny Tony
cuz that is exactly the line that
resonated with me too special shout-out
to Andy merliss by the way who put that
together you we say this all the time
it's very difficult to do with no track
but to capture all the different voices
because different cultures are so
important my Angeles you always say we
are more alike than we are different and
that's okay but always remember we are
all alike we are more alike than we are
different but there are some differences
and the differences are okay I think
that's a perfect example of God Tony I
love that people underline important
underline Asian American history is
American history yes well said well put
beautiful peace